- [Narrator] To the north and west
of Ireland's County Donegal,
is windswept Toraigh Island,
surrounded by the hungry
waves of the Atlantic.
Less than 200 people live here,
including Ireland's last and only king,
a tradition that goes back 1400 years.
- My name is Patsy Dan Rodgers,
the King of Toraigh, as they say,
and you're very welcome to Toraigh Island.
- [Narrator] As king of the island,
Patsy's role is mostly symbolic.
In the sixth century, a
visiting saint created the role
in order to unify the islanders
in defense of pirates.
But Patsy's very proud of
his island's rich heritage.
- [Patsy] We have our own Ghaeilge language.
Everyone speaks Ghaeilge on the island.
We have a very strong culture, musicians.
- [Narrator] Patsy's
duties as king are few,
but he takes his role as island
ambassador very seriously.
- People come from various
parts of the world,
from a number of countries
to meet me and to see me
on the island and to talk to me.
When I accepted the
simple honor of the king,
I thought it would never come to what
it did come to now.
It's quite serious now.
- [Narrator] Of the
roughly 150 people who live
on Toraigh Island, many
are over 65 years old,
and the island struggles for tourism
and help from the mainland.
- I am almost 70.
Many are over 70, and
the island is not going
to really depend on that type of age,
as much as we'd like to.
They would like to see now the population
of the island growing and
also a few jobs to teenagers
and the island to start swinging again.
(Irish music)
- [Narrator] Patsy may
be the only Irish king,
but his hope is that he won't be the last.
- (Patsy) When I am on my dying
bed, hopefully before that,
somebody will come up and
offer to take the honor
of the King of the Island.